today on the matt walsh show texas
recently passed a bill banning uh racist
concepts like critical race theory from
the classroom the media is now claiming
that this rule this bill somehow
requires holocaust denial
we'll try to figure out what the hell
they're talking about today also the
secretary of transportation uh bootage
has been on paternity leave for two
months and nobody noticed what does that
say about the necessity of his job and
also what about paternity leave in the
first place uh we'll talk about that and
amazon's new lord of the rings series
promises to include a cast of racially
diverse hobbits plus joe biden announces
that your five-year-old will soon be
eligible for the cove vaccine and a home
insurance ad features a young boy in
drag what does that have to do with home
insurance exactly we'll try to figure
that out today and much more on the
matte wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now a word from my favorite sponsor
genusell serum by chamonix ladies and
gentlemen take a quick look in the
mirror see those bags under your eyes
you can simply get rid of them and you
should because you all disgust me
introducing genusl plant stem cell
therapy for bags and puffiness under the
eyes uh look everyone is talking about
this rosa from new jersey wrote
i don't know where she wrote this but
she wrote it somewhere i felt the bags
under my eyes firm up and the skin was
glowing your product helped me to reduce
puffiness very fast in a couple weeks i
stopped using concealer because of the
improvement actually i've gone a week
without applying heavy makeup i would
recommend to anyone i've noticed a great
difference and i everywhere i go in
america as i travel um this land i hear
this exactly i've met so many roses
telling me the exact same thing and with
this instant effects you'll see results
in as little as 12 hours guaranteed or
your money back plus for new younger and
wrinkle-free skin chamonix will also
give you the legendary genusell xv
wrinkle treatment absolutely free just
for trying genusell today you can order
now and save big on genusell today all
packages are up to 50 off go to
genocell.com and enter matt30 for an
extra 30 off today that's genusell.com
genusell.com
as you have noticed especially if you
listen to this show there's been a lot
of attention recently on left-wing
indoctrination in schools and abuses of
power by left-wing administrators the
corporate media has ignored these issues
as much as it possibly can most outlets
have totally refused to report on the
developments in loudoun county
most of them have just said nothing at
all about it the washington post did
mention the case in an article yesterday
but the article doesn't say that the
assault happened in a bathroom doesn't
mention anything about the bathroom
policies loudoun county pushed through
it doesn't mention that the alleged
rapist was reportedly wearing a skirt it
doesn't say anything about scott smith
the father who was framed as a domestic
terrorist because he got upset that his
daughter was assaulted in other words
the washington post reported on the
story
without actually reporting on the story
and even that was far more than what
most corporate media outlets have been
willing to do
still ignore it as much as much as they
want
leftist indoctrination and corruption in
schools has become a major issue
people are clued in
they are awakened to the problem
and that's why the media's next strategy
since the blackout strategy hasn't
worked i mean that's always their first
go-to if if there's a story they don't
want to talk about
the most obvious thing is well we're not
going to talk about it
if that doesn't work then they need to
get a little bit more desperate and
that's when you get to the classic
diversion tactic
and that's why if you were to check cnn
or nbc news or the huffington post or
aoc's twitter feed yesterday or this
morning
you would have seen huge screaming
headlines
telling us uh about this story from from
this is from the nbc story that aoc
shared it says
a school administrator in texas advised
teachers last week that if they have a
book about the holocaust in their
classroom they should also have a book
with an opposing perspective
now aoc when she was sharing this adds
this concept this comment she says
there's a reason white supremacy attacks
history opposition to teaching bigotry's
history and where it leads from the
slave trade to the holocaust is about
erasing society's tools to recognize
prejudice and prevent atrocity holocaust
denial has no place in our society none
now this has been treated as a major
story
a teacher in a school district in texas
secretly recorded a meeting with a woman
named gina petty who's the district's
executive director of curriculum and
instruction
in the meeting petty is telling the
teachers about the new texas law hb 3979
which effectively bans critical race
theory
and that bill does a lot more than that
we'll get to the bill in a minute and
what it actually does
but petty is explaining to the teachers
what this bill requires and its
implications
petty it's clear from the audio
doesn't like the bill
she also doesn't understand the bill
or at least isn't telling the truth
about it whether intentionally or not
and so the school administrator in the
context of explaining a texas bill that
she doesn't like and is misconstrued
makes this claim to the teachers about
the holocaust let's um let's listen to
the audio now we are in
the middle of a political mess
and you are in the middle of a political
mess
and so we just have to do the best that
we can
and
so we're going to go and we're going to
do you're going to do what you do best
and that's to teach kids i think we're
all just really terrified i think you
are terrified and i wish i could take
that away
i i do
i can't
i can't do that you are professionals
we hired you
as professionals we trust you with our
children
so
if you think the book is okay
then let's go with it
and whatever happens we will fight it
together we will there's a lot of
districts that are in the exact same
spot we're in and no one knows how to
navigate these waters i mean no one as
you go through just try to remember the
concepts of 39.79 and make sure that if
if you have a book on the holocaust that
you have one that has a closing
that has others how do you oppose the
holocaust
believe me that's come up so
if you have a book on the holocaust make
sure you have a book that has the
opposing perspective that's that's what
uh the the petty
there says now an important point the
texas bill absolutely does not require
that schools give opposing perspectives
on the holocaust that's not what the
bill does that's total nonsense
the story here is that is that texas
passed a law
banning the political and racial
indoctrination of children in schools
which would include an effective ban on
critical race theory though that's not
the sole focus of the legislation
a school administrator doesn't like the
bill and caricatured it to her teachers
thereby misinforming them about what is
actually required of them
that's the story if it's a story at all
but that's not what the media wants us
to take from this
they want us to believe that the
administrator's interpretation is
correct this bill that this bill banning
critical race theory actually prevents
teachers from talking about the evils of
racism at all in fact the huffington
post headline about this bill when it
was passed back in june said exactly
that their headline was texas governor
signs law to stop teachers from talking
about racism
now if that was what the bill
accomplished then yeah i suppose you'd
have to talk about the holocaust
objectively quote unquote and give two
sides to the issue of whether or not
jews should be exterminated
but that's not what the bill says
here's what it says i'll read it i'll
read the relevant portion to you this is
what it says
quote for any social studies course in
the required curriculum a teacher may
not be compelled to discuss a particular
event or widely debated and currently
controversial issue of public policy or
social affairs
a teacher who chooses to discuss such a
topic shall to the best of the teacher's
ability strive to explore the topic from
diverse and contending perspectives
without giving deference to anyone to
any one perspective
okay so this is about widely debated
current events
is the holocaust a widely debated
current event no
um the point in this legislation is that
if a teacher is going to talk about some
kind of controversial current event say
vaccine mandates or gun control or
whatever they should encourage the
students to look at it from different
perspectives and they shouldn't force
their perspectives on their students
that's all
the media has decided that if teachers
can't impose their political views on
students then that means somehow they
can't even say the holocaust was bad
this is what we call a reductio ad
absurdum argument taking an entirely
reasonable idea like teachers shouldn't
bring their political biases into the
classroom and we're reducing it to an
absurdity by claiming that this would
somehow entail holocaust denial
as for the claim that the texas bill
stops teachers from talking about racism
i mean that's not a reduction to the
absurd so much as just a flat out lie in
fact the bill specifically instructs
schools to teach students about a range
of historical subjects and subjects
related to civics including this from
the legislation this is what it says
as something that they're supposed to
teach quote the history of white
supremacy including but not limited to
the institution of slavery the eugenics
movement and the kkk and the ways in
which it is morally wrong
that's in the bill
so
while the media democrats say that the
bill bans teachers from talking about
racism it actually instructs them to
talk about it
right there in plain language
in fact in in that uh the huffington
post article that says teachers are
banned from talking about racism
they do include the bill itself that you
can read and you just read the bill and
it says the opposite of the headline
not only that but it bans the practice
of racism in the classroom
so you talk about racism but you can't
actually be racist in the classroom as a
teacher
that's what the bill says again from the
legislation it says the teachers shall
not quote
be required to engage in training
orientation or therapy
that presents any form of race or sex
stereotyping or blame on the basis of
race or sex
or require or make part of a course the
concept that
one race or sex is inherently superior
or that an individual by virtue of the
individual's race or sex is inherently
racist sexist or oppressive
that's again in the build this is not a
prohibition
of the discussion of racism in the
classroom
it's a prohibition of racism itself in
the classroom
a teacher could talk about racism
but it can't actually be racist or teach
racist concepts
so the reality is always is exactly the
opposite of what the media presents
and this is their real problem with the
bill by the way
the kind of racism just described
casting blame and guilt on the basis of
race
that's exactly what the media and
democrats want in the classroom
that's what alexandra caser cortez wants
in the classroom
and everywhere else in society
and no matter what else whatever else
they say or claim that's the real
problem with it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i'm very happy to introduce an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about it's called get
upside my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back don't pay full price of the pump
anymore get the cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
per gallon cashback on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back and there's no
catch the cash back gets added right to
your account
uh this is free money it's easy to do
why wouldn't you do it you can cash out
any time to your bank account paypal or
an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands it really is as simple as that
all you got to do is just download the
free get upside app and use promo code
walsh to get up to 50
uh rather i should say 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your first tank that
again is codewalsh at the get upside app
uh i do have to i mean i have to
acknowledge some big news over um on the
youtube channel we did get to 400 000
subscribers
uh so
it has been
and i i i i it seems like we just we
just celebrated
um with uh i think it was with my
tremendous banjo performance 300 000
subscribers not long ago so the channel
is uh is growing fast and i'm very
grateful for that
i'm very happy about it
and in fact to
acknowledge
are 400 000 subscribers i will now
perform
a celebratory gesture
are you ready
wow that was exciting
now let's uh let's move on and if you're
just listening to the audio you have no
idea what you just missed
you'll never know
uh we'll start with this this is a this
is kind of an interesting case and i
have a
a few different angles to to attack this
this story from
um but we'll start with the daily wire
report it says transportation secretary
pete buttigieg has reportedly been on
paid leave for months
as the u.s is facing a historic supply
chain crisis that is causing pain for
americans throughout the course of their
daily lives
uh politico reported quote while u.s
ports face anchor to anchor traffic and
congress nearly melted down over the
president's infrastructure bill in
recent weeks the usually omnipresent
transportation secretary bootage was
lying low
they didn't previously announce it but
buddhija's office told west wing
playbook that the secretary has actually
been on paid leave since mid-august
to spend time with his husband jason and
their two newborn babies
a spokesperson for the department told
politico that buddhist was mostly
offline for the first four weeks except
for major agency decisions and matters
that could not be delegated
um he's been ramping up the activities
since then
according to a spokesperson adding that
budage will continue to take some time
over the coming weeks to support his
husband and take care of his new
children
senator marcia blackburn byrne
right here in tennessee
slammed buddage in a statement to
breitbart news on thursday saying we're
in the middle of a transportation crisis
and pete budget is sitting at home
meanwhile cargo boats are unable to dock
and shelves are sitting empty pete needs
to either get back to work or leave the
department of transportation it's time
to put american families first
okay
so is
uh this is this is pretty incredible
we're in the middle of a transportation
crisis
and the transportation secretary has
been at home since mid-august
with no plans of returning it's been two
months and he's saying well he's gonna
start ramping up activities now start
ramping it up
so he's two months into his paternity
leave
where he's getting paid to sit at home
with no plans of returning yet
and meanwhile this is a cabinet
secretary
someone appointed by the biden
administration
has been off the job since the middle of
the since uh you know the middle of
august and nobody even noticed until
right now
that's a government job for you okay
that that is a job that that is a
bureaucracy for you
where you can disappear
for two months and it it it'll be eight
weeks before anyone says hey what
whatever happened to that guy
which guy oh you know buddha do you mean
the guy that runs this whole thing
oh yeah yeah we haven't really seen him
around
then they give him a call oh yeah guys
i've been here since i've been here
since august
that's that's the way it works in a
bureaucracy
i mean it can't work that way in the
private sector right
because you know when you you have a job
where you actually have to perform a
function and you're needed to do a
certain thing and if you if you don't do
the job people are going to notice
um
i'm just a podcast host for god's sake
but but i'm pretty sure that if i didn't
i don't think i could not show up to
work for for two months and nobody would
notice
um
so he gets two months and counting of
paid
paternity leave
and i think so there's a couple things
that this tells us
first of all
if you are able
to disappear from your job for two
months
and nobody notices
then that's a really good indication
that your job is not necessary
okay
if if there if there are jobs in
government where we can afford to lose
you for two months then that job needs
to be gone
we need to eliminate that job
um
what about paternity leave itself
okay
now as you know i i speak on this
subject as a as a as a man with four
kids
so um i know of what i speak
and this is one of those issues where
you've got a lot of childless people who
are chiming in
and it's very clear that they're
childless because they don't know what
they're talking
about so i'll say about paternity leave
first of all
for for public employees you're working
for the government you're on the
taxpayer dime
i i'm not you know i'll be generous i'm
i'm the boss right you're the boat we're
the boss we're the one paying the the uh
the salaries here we're supposed to be
the bosses
and so as the boss is paying the salary
my
your salary as a public employee that
comes out of my check i got to pay for
that
and no i'm not paying for you to sit
home
for two months i'm not paying for that
i shouldn't have to pay for that
um
so for public employees we could be
generous and say fine you want to take
paternity leave for a week
i'll i'll i'll go that far that's that's
what a generous person i am two months
is insane
there should not be anyone on the public
taxpayer dime sitting home and not doing
their job for two months
i mean you want to sit home and
prioritize your family and just be with
your family you're perfectly free to do
that but we got to find someone else
because the public needs this job to be
done
and we can't afford to pay you to not do
it and again if we don't need this job
to be done so we can afford it then the
job should just be eliminated
completely we
the public either needs that job done or
not
and if we need it done then do it
um
even in the private sector i mean you
know
private companies can come up with
whatever whatever paternity leave
policies they want
and if you work for a company that will
let you stay home on paternity leave for
two months then i mean god bless you i
guess take advantage of that
but two months in general you know
months of paternity leave is it really
is absurd i'm sorry
again speaking as a father of four i can
tell you okay
there is very little for a father to do
in the in the in the early stages of a
child's life in the newborn phase
there's not much for a father to do
especially if the mother's breastfeeding
and if the mother presumably is taking
maternity leave and she's breastfeeding
then um all here's here's what a babe
here's what a newborn baby does after
four of them i can tell you
uh a newborn baby eats
and uh sleeps
and poops but that those are the only
things that newborn baby doesn't newborn
baby doesn't do anything but that that's
it
and sleeping the baby's sleeping eating
that the mom's gonna take care of that
and yeah i mean you could be on the hook
to change the poopy diapers and so that
you could be helpful in that regard
but that's pretty much it for newborn
baby
um
as far as bonding time you know i was
talking about this on twitter and people
were saying well it's also the father
needs bonding time okay yeah you want to
stay home for a week and have some
bonding time i mean two months of
two months of bonding time where you're
still getting paid to not work is
ridiculous
but even that again i'm just telling you
that there's not a lot of bonding that
the father is going to do in that in
those early stages of life because the
newborn baby is all about the mom
that's that's just the reality
for the father the really important
bonding time comes a little bit later in
life i mean if anything if we're talking
about paternity leave for bonding time
then that should start like at their
when they at their first birthday or
something that that's when the most
important bonding time for the father
really kicks in a little bit later in
the child's life
so we should be talking about that if
that's that's what this is all about
but you know the great news is i've i've
never had any kind of paternity leave
and uh and yet i'm still very well
bonded with all my kids i mean you can
still work and do your job and also bond
with your kids
and i don't want to hear anything about
how this is oh this is capitalism
prioritizing
you know income and and
over families
what do you think
pre-industrial times
in non-capitalist societies
you think fathers would would a baby was
born they were just doing nothing for
two months and sitting at home no
there are still jobs that need to be
done
and what makes us all the more absurd in
budapest's case is that
yeah the father does have a really
important role
early in the child's life
but the most important role and if you
are staying home for a week or two
months as the dad
the main thing that you that you that
you got to be doing
if you have other kids you know you're
going to be doing the lion's share of
that's like the main one when we have
more kids and
you know
with our most recent child we had three
other kids and so
my wife was taking care of the baby
mostly and i was taking care of the
older kids
um but if you don't have any other kids
then
your main role as the dad once the baby
is born is you're taking care of your
wife you're taking care of the mom
she's the one who's taking care of the
baby most the time you're taking care of
her as she physically recovers from the
from the birth
but pete budage doesn't have a mom to
take care of there's no one who's
physically recovering from any kind of
birth
so i'm not sure exactly what he's even
doing for those two months
nothing he's just sitting around having
a nice vacation okay
um
let's see what else we got here
i thought this was this was a
interesting
given the timing of it
so i'm going to read from the daily mail
it says the chairman of nike's
successful jordan brand
has revealed that he murdered an
innocent 18 year old boy in 1965 while
he was a gang member
larry miller 72 announced wednesday in a
sports illustrated interview that he
served time in prison after fatally
shooting edward white when he was a 16
year old member of philly's cedar avenue
gang
miller says he took to the streets
drunkenly in search of revenge after one
of his friends and fellow gang members
was fatally stabbed by a member of the
rival 53rd and pine gang
um
53rd and pine that's a gang it sounds
like a boutique clothing shop
the business tycoon didn't know white
didn't know the victim but wanted to
avenge the murder of a fellow gang
member and says he ended up shooting and
killing the first person that he saw so
he just went
he did this this wasn't even really a
revenge killing you found some random
person and simply killed him
um
white did nothing to provoke him and
there's no suggestion he was a member of
any other gang he died on the spot after
being shot with a 38 miller and
miller had gotten from his from his
girlfriend
um
and
why is miller telling us this story now
apparently he had kind of kept kept this
to himself as he was climbing up the
corporate ladder and he's a very
successful person now running the jordan
brand
uh and he's he is now revealing all of
this because it's in a book that he's
that he's selling and so he's doing the
book tour and talking about this
dramatic story wherein he
commits first-degree murder of an
innocent person and that's in the book
and everything now
what makes this interesting is that
you know he's
of course no one's calling for him to be
fired or anything like that i mean he
has it in a book he's he's promoting
he's promoting his book based on this
story of murdering somebody
and uh you know most of the media
headlines are talking about how brave it
is that he's coming out about this and
it's a story about redemption and
forgiveness and all those kinds of
things
and that's that's all fine i mean
i would say you're you're 72 year old
man you committed this horrible crime
decades and decades ago you went to
prison and served your time
um
i'm i'm i i think a story of red and he
has a lot of remorse about it
he talks about how it has the guilt has
plagued him and everything
um
i didn't read anything in the story
about whether he has tracked down the
family of his victim and tried to help
them in some way hopefully he's done
that
so a story about redemption and
forgiveness i'm all about that i think
that's great
somebody commits a horrible crime goes
to prison serves out their time leaves
is able to
still live a a a productive life after
the fact i think that's great too
but it's just interesting that
we can accept this kind of
redemption
and we can have forgiveness for
something like this
in our society
and yet if you said
vulgar words in a private email
10 years ago
that is
unforgivable that's the interesting
thing to me
and you could easily
uh home in on the on the racial aspect
of this larry miller is a black man
uh john gruden's a white guy that makes
john gruden a lot less sympathetic in
the eyes of the media and much of the
culture and there is that but that's not
all what this that's that's not the
whole story here
it's also just that these days we really
do see
murder
as less
of a crime
less of a moral failing
than
using politically incorrect language
you know if if if larry miller had
revealed his own emails if rather than
have having killed someone
when he was a teenager
if he had revealed his only or i guess
back then it would have been letters
that he'd written
you know where he used like the f slur
for gay people or something like that
if that's what he was revealing
something tells me that people would be
much less accepting of his redemption
arc in that case because our priorities
are so wildly
out of whack
all right next this is from uh
the daily wire as
uh the daily wire and uh luke rosiak
here investigative journalists continue
to follow this story in loudoun county
and it's it's good that we're following
the story of loudoun county because as
we talked about at the top of the show
the media the corporate media has no
interest whatsoever in this in this
story
so here's the latest and it keeps
getting worse
says loudoun county public schools did
not record multiple known incidents of
alleged sexual assault in schools dating
back several years despite a law that
requires statistics about school safety
incidents to be reported to the public
and which includes provisions holding
school superintendents personally liable
for violations
after the daily wire raised the
descriptive discrepancy with the
virginia department of education
the spokesman charles pyle said that the
vdoe is reviewing the discipline crime
and violence data submissions of loudoun
county public schools and is in
communication with lcps to determine
whether the division's reporting is
accurate and whether the division is in
compliance with state and federal law
the same law could have implications for
a loudon superintendent or principle in
the wake of a may 28th alleged sexual
assault and bathroom which we've talked
about so
now we have multiple alleged sexual
assaults um
which which were not recorded
or reported
and that shouldn't surprise you because
as we discussed on the show yesterday
this is an epidemic in the public school
system
while you're fighting in loudoun county
i mean you could dig in
to
hundreds of different school districts
across the country and you're going to
find similar things
sexual assaults in the school system
student on student
teacher on student
that are not recorded not reported
teachers are moved around all the rest
of it
this is happening this is this is a
it's a big story in loudoun county
but this is a classic tip of the iceberg
type of thing
um it goes much deeper than that
it's ju it's it's like in the catholic
church
we started hearing reports out of boston
and uh what was happening
up in boston with with pedophile priests
getting moved around
and then you start digging deeper into
it and you find out that okay this is
happening all across the country
because that's the way it always works
you know it's the these kinds of
problems are when you when they're in a
system like this they're never going to
be contained to one little piece one
little
part part of the system
it's always going to be system wide
um
and it's it's it's a it's a good thing
that daily wire is here to
not to tutor on our own horn but
this is just not a story that the media
is going to chase down
even taking the trans bathroom angle out
of it
because all of these other thousands and
thous tens of thousands of cases of
sexual assault that have happened in our
schools over the last several years
most of them have nothing to do with
bathrooms have nothing to do with any of
that
and still the media doesn't want to talk
about it
abuse in the catholic church sure that's
fantastic as far as they're concerned
because they hate catholicism they hate
the catholic church they they hate what
it represents
and so if they can find this kind of
evil and moral hypocrisy
uh and and these predators in the
catholic church then for them that uh
that that fits perfectly into the
narrative
and they will chase those those kinds of
stories down
fearlessly because what is there to fear
uh captain in the public school it's an
entirely different deal
all right this is from the website
gamespot it says actor sir lenny henry
has shared some new insight on amazon's
the lord of the rings tv show which will
feature a diverse multicultural cast and
a very strong female presence
speaking of the bbc henry said that he
plays a harfoot which is a type of
hobbit described by tolkien in his
writing as having darker skin uh he said
quote i'm a harfoot because j.r.r
tolkien who was from birmingham suddenly
there were black hobbits i'm a black
hobbit it's brilliant
um
and then he continues and said
in this new series there are black and
asian
and brown
um
hobbits it's a whole brand new set of
adventures that that seed some of the
origins of different characters then he
also talks about how there's he says
there's a very strong female presence in
this
uh they're going to be female heroes in
this and they're going to be little
people as usual okay well
first of all there were there were
female heroes in the original lord of
the ranks trilogy if i remember
correctly
uh i'm not
not an expert on tolkien's mythology but
i do remember that at least
and again as not an expert on tolkien
mythology i'm i'm pretty sure if i
remember the movies and the books uh
correctly
that the hobbit hobbits are from
you know a small region of middle earth
so the idea that you would have this
this wide array
of racial diversity
that you have asian hobbits in middle
earth where there is as far as i am
aware no asia in in in the context of
that mythology that doesn't actually
make a lot of sense
i mean yeah you might have darker and
lighter skin tones just like you have
anywhere else
but i'm not sure how how you get racial
diversity
from this small little region of middle
earth
and and i know you you could easily say
well who cares it's all fiction it's all
it's all fantasy you can do what you
want and i get that
but even so
it doesn't make sense within tolkien's
mythology it doesn't actually make sense
within the story
and so why are they doing it if all they
cared about was was tr staying true to
the story and telling the story
then you wouldn't have this they're
doing this because they there there are
things that they care more about
you know there are things they
prioritize over the story itself
and one of those things is checking the
boxes
so the first priority when they set out
to tell this
tale
about middle earth and about this
mythological tale their first priority
is not let's tell a great story let's
stay true to tolkien's mythology that's
that's not it the first priority is
you know we've got all these boxes of
representation let's check them all off
we've got to have x number of female
characters we got to have x number of
black characters asian characters
of course we got to you know we got to
figure out a way to ram some some gay
characters in here
can we get a transgender hobbit i'm sure
we can
that becomes the first party then
everything else is secondary
and uh
i i simply have no tolerance for it
so this this
this show for me is checked off the list
i was actually kind of looking forward
to it but
the moment
the moment i notice the pc box checking
the moment they do it
i i have no tolerance for it anymore
i don't want to see it
i'm not going to waste my time with it
it's it's this complete fourth wall
breaking moment
where they're taking us out of the story
they're telling they're taking us out of
the fantasy and the mythology they're
taking us away from middle earth
and they're putting us right here in in
the year 2021 in this confused
politically correct culture of ours
you
know and they're making sure that
everything being shown in this fantasy
story aligns with the you know values
and needs of uh of of of american
culture in the year 2021 it just it
annihilates the fourth wall takes you
out of the story and it's what's the
point anymore
all right
let's go next to this joe biden had a
big announcement about vaccines for
children that i suppose his parents were
supposed to be excited about you could
tell me if
if that's how you feel about it here it
is
now i know parents uh
out there are anxiously waiting for a
vaccine for children ages 5 to 11.
the good news is the fda and outside
experts in the cdc are set to make its
determination as to whether the vaccine
will be authorized for that age range in
the next few weeks
if authorized we are ready
we have purchased enough vaccines for
all children between the ages of 5 and
11 in the united states
and will be it'll be convenient for
parents to get their children vaccinated
at trusted locations
and families will be able to sleep
easier at night
knowing their kids are protected as well
um i mean i've been sleeping fine at
night
except when the kid
is in bed with us because he had a
nightmare and is
kicking me in the face all night um
but as far as covet goes i've been
sleeping perfectly fine
you know as a parent if you've been
losing any sleep
worried about your kids in covid
then
that's a sign of your of your own
extreme paranoia
um
he says the good news is that the fda is
approving vaccine for kids
no the good news is that your kids have
this thing called
an immune system
and as it happens
their immune system
and this is not the case for people in
older age groups necessarily but for
them
their immune system provides them even
better protection
than the vaccine does for older age
groups that's the good news
and in fact uh
joe rogan
had dr gupta from cnn on his show a
couple couple days ago
and he he was trying to make this point
about the vaccines and kids and this and
this kind of natural immunity that kids
have natural immunity in the sense of
their their natural immune system
provides them such profound protection
he was trying to to make this point to
gupta and there there's this disconnect
that you can see let's let's watch it
don't you think that even with a
breakthrough infection untreated you're
probably more vulnerable than the
average child who is not vaccinated who
gets coveted
like people have died who are double
vaccinated in fact there was a guy who
just won an emmy who's uh yeah i saw
that yeah the odds of that happening to
a healthy child are very very low very
low but that guy is probably your age
how old are you i'm 51. yeah he's about
your age theoretically you would be more
vulnerable than a young child would be
you vaccinated would be more vulnerable
of a breakthrough infection than a young
child would be statistically speaking
right but you're not worried they're
both rare but you're not worried about
catching it
you're not worried about catching it
because you've been vaccinated and you
think it imparts a certain amount of
protection what i'm saying to you is i
think that not worry is the same feeling
that a lot of people have about their
children they're not worried about their
healthy children catching it for the
same reason you're not worried about
catching it being vaccinated that if
treated correctly
they think that the child probably has
a better chance even than you do
because you're 51 years old i i think
does that
i mean they're they're both that seems
reasonable right well i think it's i
don't i i i know the story about this 50
feet
what i'm saying like with your attitude
that you're not worried about catching
it because
you've been vaccinated and you're a
healthy guy that is the exact same
feeling that people have about
vaccinating their children if they have
healthy children and they know that
statistically speaking there's so few
children that have died from covet
well yeah there there are it's like i
think 500 or so children have millions
and millions and millions of kids that
probably have been exposed yeah and but
you know it's again part of it is is not
defining this in terms of life and death
this is
it's never going to get through it can't
get through
like what
kid this this is not really a risk for
kids why are we acting like it's a risk
you know
uh
what what's what's the reason for that
this is just it's a question that's
never going to get through
and so you see he keeps he keeps he
keeps trying to bring it back to that
but
it is it's like it's like talking to a
tree or something
people have committed to this idea
that everybody you know
everybody has to treat covet exactly the
same
we are all
i guess this is the principles of equity
being applied to uh to
covet
and to science
we are all equally as susceptible to
covet
even if we're not we're going to pretend
that we are including our kids
all right one other thing i have to show
you uh i mean i don't have to show you
this but i'm going to and god forgive me
i beg your forgiveness um
but no not this one we're gonna get to
that in a second
yeah there we go
so this this is this is the thing in
fact let's put up no we won't show the
video of her dancing but lizzo let's
just show the pictures there okay there
we go
so lizzo uh the singer lizzo showed up
to cardi b's birthday party a few days
ago
and uh i only know about this by the way
because this was all over like twitter
for days
had we kept kept pushing these headlines
about lizzo at cardi b's birthday party
in a totally see-through dress
so lizzo went to the liz who is you know
i should remind you she's morbidly obese
and if you're looking at the picture i
don't need to remind you of that it's
it's right there in your face you can
quite clearly see it but a morbidly
obese pop singer uh she goes to
cardi b's birthday party uh in a
see-through dress and with nothing on
underneath
okay
twitter really wanted us to see this and
so for days and days they were pushing
this headline out
and of course the media talking about
how beautiful and amazing this is and
what a beautiful dress it is
and if you look at some of the reaction
on social media
well a lot of seemingly normal people
insisting oh she's gorgeous this is
beautiful
and nobody actually thinks that right
but we've been convinced to deny so many
basic truths
that we know deep down to be true but
we've been we've we have been
uh uh
scolded and yelled at so much that we've
been we have been
many of us convinced to suppress those
truths that we recognize and that that
includes basic truths about biological
science and everything else
there's also a truth to beauty i mean
beauty is not despite what you're told
in the eye of the beholder
there is an objective quality to beauty
and so you look at uh
i don't know the sun setting over the
ocean
that's beautiful and if anybody were to
to
be standing on that beach with you and
looking at this uh looking at that sky
and the sun setting over the ocean they
were to say that's disgusting ew ugly um
no it's this is not a matter of them
having a different opinion that's
totally valid they're wrong i mean
they're probably mentally ill that would
be a sign that someone is mentally ill
if they were somehow disgusted by this
what is an objectively beautiful sight
um
and it goes the other way too
i mean i'm a morbidly obese woman
walking around a see-through dress that
that is that is not a beautiful sight it
simply is not
and if you're saying that it is you're
probably lying and you know that you're
lying
or you're lying and you don't know it
because you because society has told you
that you're not allowed to recognize
okay take the pictures down stop showing
them
let's take the pictures off i think
we've seen enough
uh
society has told you that you're not
allowed to recognize the objective
quality to physical beauty because there
is an objective quality there
you know we're told that through
different cultures and different
societies throughout history have had
different standards of beauty and yeah
that's basically true
but if you were to look at who would be
considered
i mean prior to when we all lost our
minds
who would have been considered a what
woman would have been considered a
beautiful woman in our culture that
would woman would have been considered
beautiful in any culture throughout
history
some slight differences but
there's really no culture except ours
that would ever insist that morbid
obesity is beautiful
and it can't be beautiful because it's
suicidal it's destructive
you're you're watching someone kill
themselves slowly what's that can't be
beautiful
it's not beautiful to watch someone
destroy themselves
and by the way a see-through dress on
anyone
is
why are you putting pictures up again we
don't no
i'm please i'm trying to get through
this segment right now please
uh
what was i even saying
the the
a see-through address on anyone is
trashy and gross on anybody i mean
that's that's that's a trashy and
embarrassing thing to do
it's also something you dress like that
because you hate yourself that is a
self-loathing self-hating thing to do
because you don't see the dignity
you don't see your own dignity
and so the other thing that we're told
when we see a dress like that is not
only is it beautiful which it isn't
clearly uh but we're also told that this
is you know if you love yourself and
you're confident about yourself this is
how you address this is a sign of her
confidence
well we know that's not the case in fact
we played the video a few weeks ago
where lizzo was crying on instagram live
because some of the mean comments people
have made about her
that's an honest moment i mean this is
someone who very much has a lot of
self-doubt
and um
and you you know that not just from
crying on instagram live but because
that's what you do
that's that is overcompensation to an
extreme degree
if you really love yourself then you
would respect your own dignity
and going out like that
is undignified
all right we gotta we gotta just keep
moving on i think this is a message from
the control room to just move to the
next topic
uh because they keep flashing
lizzo's
naked butt at me so we're gonna we're
gonna move now to reading the comments
who's rocking polka dots without
shame do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
okay
good uh
let's see first comment says matt what
is your opinion on the actor and
comedian matt walsh whenever i google
your name he comes up first
uh you know i have no problem with him i
i think that probably
he
i i you know i gotta say i think he's
the the
the victim in this in our shared name
um
yeah he's a hollywood actor he i assume
he's
the pretty safe assumption that he's
left wing
i don't mind look i i embrace all matt
walsh's i i think that i wish that there
was a brotherhood that we we all share
in our name but i just don't know if
that feeling is returned i suspect that
it's not a mutual feeling
um
shiffy
weinberg says why don't all parents of
loudoun county stop sending their
children to school for two weeks or even
longer that might get the message across
uh
yeah i think that
that's an interesting idea
i think that's uh that's some sort of
i mean going going to the school board
meetings and speaking out is an
important thing to do
but loudoun county is making that as
difficult as possible and again they
only give you the 60 seconds which is
absurd
so
yeah if i was still a resident of
loudoun county then uh then which maybe
i will become a resident again
in the future who knows
i i would be looking at uh at other
methods of sending the message across
on top of going to school board meetings
uh
slightly offended says why doesn't the
vice resident give up any land or house
that she owns
she's so sad and hurt by what those in
her family have done
then take action
well right if you believe that you're on
stolen land see i have there's no moral
quandary for me this idea that we are on
stolen land that we're all thieves i
don't i don't buy that i don't accept it
i don't believe that i don't think that
and so i'm gonna go about living my life
but if you actually believe that you are
on stolen land and yet you continue to
live on it
well that morally that makes you a thief
you know i don't have the moral guilt of
a thief because i simply don't accept
the president the premise at all
but if you really believe that premise
if you actually believe
that your land is stolen that you have
no right to be on it and yet you remain
there
then you have that moral the mo that's
that's the irony the moral guilt that
you're trying to hoist in everybody else
actually lays at your own feet
unless you don't believe it which makes
you a hypocrite and then you have that
moral guilt so pick your poison
uh david says i wish you were my daddy
and you could put me back to sleep after
a bad dream david
no
don't you're taking liberties with a
sweet daddy thing that that are not
acceptable and you are banned from the
show i did how dare you sir
uh
major tom fisher says
was thinking about the question about
daily wire's future movies and now i
really want to see dw buy big idea back
from dreamworks and finally bring back
veggietales
bringing it back to its home in
tennessee too
i tell you right now if daily wire buys
veggie tails i quit
i want no part of that
um
and uh let's see what else we got
luke says are you gonna do a review of
the new adele song
no because i only review songs that are
terrible
that's the rule
and i did hear that adele has a new song
out apparently and uh i did hear it and
it wasn't bad
she can actually sing like it's a she's
actually singing a song and there's
music in the background
and uh so it's like it's a it's a song
and my standards are pretty low these
days for pop music
uh bh says who the hell is matt walsh
have you guys ever watched the jordan
harbinger show even matt knows deep down
his show sucks compared to the jordan
harbinger show jordan harbinger is the
real leader of the sweet baby gang
well i can't deny that bh i think you're
i think you're exactly right
what are you all doing here
when you should be listening to jordan
harbinger show we had a lot of exciting
announcements to make at our show of our
showing of backstage at the ryman this
past tuesday because daily wire is
fulfilling their promises of bringing
you even more non-work content that you
literally will not find anywhere else
and a very special guest helped us to
deliver one of those announcements our
good friend adam carolla comedian and
host of the attic world show corolla is
joining the daily wire for a comedy
series that'll deliver the laughs you
need with the truth you deserve and we
can't wait to share the final product
with you the first few episodes will
drop in november with more to come early
next year so there's no better time to
join us than right now head to
dailywire.com subscribe and enter code
code 2022 for 25 off your membership
that's dailywire.com subscribe code
2022 for 25 off a daily wire membership
you know it's been an exciting week for
this week for the daily wire and this
weekend sunday special only adds to the
excitement ben will be joined uh by none
other than barry weiss a brilliant
writer journalist and now the voice of
her own excellent podcast called
honestly they sit down to make sense of
all that's been going on today and it
truly is worth a listen go check it out
this sunday at dailywire.com or on ben's
youtube channel ben shapiro daily wire
members get access to special bonus
content from sunday special episodes so
don't miss out join daily wire today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel
john lewis um not the late congressman
but the uk company which provides home
insurance among other things the
company's been making some headlines
mostly positive headlines over in
inclusive
and progressive new advertisement which
features as so many ads do these days
a young boy cross-dressing now the ad
title we just play the ad here while i'm
talking um so you could see the the ad
is titled let life happen and it opens
with the boy in what appears to be his
sister's room
kind of dolled up in uh in girl clothes
with makeup smeared all over his face
and he's got jewelry on and he's got
he's got high heels
and the room is completely trashed and
torn apart
and then an area is there
and the boy begins dancing through the
house and he's at one point he's
smearing paint on the walls kicking over
lamps
tearing books off the shelves
uh he knocks over his sister's paints
and he spills them on the carpet
towards the end he throws glitter all
over the living room he starts dancing
on top of the table
and then you see at one point his mother
is looking on with a blank expression
and then the ad ends with the words let
life happen home
insurance so that's the ad
now before we even get to the issue of
the buoyant address
i think there are a number of basic
concept problems with this ad
the first is that no insurance company
on earth i can tell you this right now
including john lewis i'm quite sure
will cover damage to your home which has
been caused intentionally by your bratty
child while you sat there and watched
anyone who's ever dealt with home
insurance companies knows that home
insurance in general is great until you
actually have to use it okay the
insurance companies would prefer that
you just pay them each month and never
actually use the product you've been
paying for if you do dare to file a
claim they're almost offended when you
when you call them up and say i gotta
file a claim what you what do you mean
you gotta file a claim
they'll do everything in their power to
ensure that your claim isn't covered by
the policy you paid for
there's almost always some fine print
technicality like you call and say that
you have a burst pipe and they'll say uh
well when when did the pipe burst and
you'll say it happen on tuesday morning
and they'll say oh well uh oh
unfortunately if the pipe burst on
tuesday between 6 15 a.m and 8 17 a.m we
can't cover it that wasn't your policy
it's up you know unfortunately we just
we just can't
so my point is that
they definitely aren't covering the
damage done by your out-of-control son
during his impromptu drag performance
even if they say they will they won't
but maybe that's neither here nor there
the real point is that the marketing
agency that made this ad went out and
hired a young boy dressed them up in
makeup and heels and told them to dance
around the house while they film him
why
well because the people behind this ad
are a bunch of creepy disgusting freaks
and like all the other creepy disgusting
freaks who run our culture they really
want your child to be gender fluid they
especially want this for young boys i
mean when you see this kind of thing in
mainstream advertisements advertisements
for normal everyday products like home
insurance
then you see all the books in the
children's section of barnes noble that
feature boys dressing like girls and you
see the drag queen story hours and all
the rest of it it becomes quite clear
that the promotion of gender ideology
has become the priority number one for
our cultural overlords
it's the most important thing to them
they desperately want your kids to buy
in especially your sons
so it's it's uh
interesting to note that
the majority of kids who fall into the
trap and start identifying as gender
fluid or trans are girls
this kind of thing is the most common
among adolescent girls these days and
yet it would seem
that most of the effort is put into
inducting boys into the cult
why is that well
i think girls reach a certain age right
around puberty
when they're especially susceptible to
the to the um
to the gender cult
you know they go through a period of
feeling uncomfortable in their own
bodies not at home in their bodies uh
boys may have something like that as
well but it's not nearly as pronounced
the gender cult gives girls a framework
for understanding these natural and
fleeting feelings the cultists sees on
this normal phase of girlhood and use it
as a wedge to pry girls away from their
true and natural identities with boys it
would seem the job is harder
boys have their own bewildering
experiences and puberty but it's not the
same
and the feelings of physical alienation
within your own body are again not
nearly as powerful in boys as they are
in girls which means that if the gender
cultists want to get to boys they need
to start younger
and they need to be more aggressive
they need to try harder
and that's why it's almost always boys
being targeted by these kinds of things
even as girls make up the majority of
the kids who ultimately fall victim to
it
but the funny thing about this ad
is that it actually makes the opposite
point from the one that it's trying to
make
because the boy in the ad
is immature
out of control
childish destructive
when left to his own devices when his
mother just sits there and lets him do
what he wants offering no guidance or
correction at all
he makes himself and the home into a
disaster zone
the boy can't be given that kind of free
reign he needs instruction he needs
careful parental oversight
that's not what the ad is trying to
demonstrate but that's what it did
demonstrate
and that's also why you can't let kids
choose their own gender because they
lack the maturity and discernment and
long-term decision-making ability to to
determine that for themselves
of course nobody can determine it for
themselves because biology determines it
but children especially can't be given
that kind of power
and so
the ad
would seem to illustrate that for us
quite profoundly and also quite
unintentionally
when you as a parent just sit there
drinking your coffee
letting your kid live their life
without giving any guidance
you know
letting them alone in the dark to fumble
their way through
without grabbing the flashlight yourself
and saying no child this this is the way
to go
when you do that this is what what you
end up with
you end up with a boy wearing drag
tearing your house apart
so
for that reason
although they ultimately made the
correct point unintentionally we still
have to say that uh john lewis home
insurance
and really maybe all home insurance in
the end
is canceled
and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin